forbes released picks for its 2022
fintech 50 list which highlights 50 of
the most innovative companies in the
financial technology space
to qualify for the fintech 50 a company
must either have headquarters or
substantial operations in the us and be
private as of the date of publication
the startups on the fintech 50 cover a
wide range of financial services and
cater to both regular consumers as well
as b2b
what we saw this year was that it was
our hardest year yet in trying to
determine what are the 50 most
innovative fintech companies there's a
ton of energy flowing into the space a
ton of money
fintech startups received about 130
billion in funding in 2021 compared with
49 billion in 2020 another thing that
resulted from from all of this energy
and money flowing into the space that
this year we had 25 newcomers to the
west and so half of the list were
companies that have never been on the
list before we've never had that many
newcomers
here is an example of five of this
year's 50 list makers and the specific
areas they cover ftx is probably one of
the most well-known on the list
especially for investors in
cryptocurrencies
based in nassau capital of the bahamas
it's one of the largest crypto trading
exchanges in the world handling about 11
of the 2.4 trillion dollars in
derivatives traded each month a 500
million dollar fundraise this past
january took the company's valuation to
32 billion dollars its separate us
entity is valued at eight billion
dollars and ftx has been spending
hundreds of millions of dollars on
marketing signing up celebrity brand
ambassadors such as tom brady david
ortiz and kevin o'leary the company's
co-founders are ceo sam bankman freed
who is the world's second richest crypto
billionaire and cto gary wang
chainalysis has been involved with
helping to solve some of the world's
highest profile criminal cases involving
digital assets including the seizure of
3.5 billion dollars worth of crypto by
the irs criminal investigation unit the
new york based company now screens one
trillion dollars in transaction value
each month across all cryptocurrency
assets and itself is valued at 8.6
billion dollars
over the past year chanalysis has
increased its customer base by 75
and now has more than 750 clients in 70
countries its co-founders are ceo
michael groninger a phd in quantum
mechanics who previously co-founded the
crypto exchange kraken and chief
strategy officer jonathan levin novo is
aiming to replace the big banks as the
go-to provider of checking accounts and
other banking services for small
businesses
based in miami the company took a slow
and steady approach it was founded in
2016 but did not launch until two years
later it got by on under seven million
dollars in seed capital and a federal
ppp forgivable loan until mid 2021 when
it started raising serious expansion
funds novo's latest valuation is 700
million dollars and its customer base
grew exponentially from 24 000 to 140
000 in 2021 capitalizing on the burst of
small business creation in the us its
co-founders are ceo michael rangel and
cto tyler mcintyre plaid is a san
francisco-based company which helps
fintech apps such as venmo and coinbase
connect to customer bank accounts
allowing for deposits and payments
its latest valuation is 13.4 billion
dollars and it paid 250 million dollars
to acquire cognito an identity
verification service and know your
customer or kyc compliance provider
plaid has raised 735 million dollars in
venture capital from altimeter capital
anderson horowitz and others its
co-founders are ceo zach parrott and
former cto william hockey who was the
co-founder of column a newcomer on this
year's fintech 50. finally bridget is a
financial app aimed at helping americans
living paycheck to paycheck build up
their money management skills and credit
scores while avoiding bank overdrafts
and payday advance loans the
subscription-based service links a
user's bank account and approves them
for an interest-free loan of 50 to 250
a free version of the app provides
advice but no loans
the company is valued at 140 million
dollars and has almost a half a million
paying users and three million accounts
using the free features the new york
based company was co-founded by ceo
zubin matthews who was an investment
maker with deutsche bank for a decade
and cto hamel kathari who was a member
of the 2021 forbes 30 under 30 list